supposedly this is the final Paranormal
Activity movie can we be so lucky we put
all our chips in that basket and
actually professed to the universe it's
the fun of jet ski we are Paranormal
Activity the ghost dimension so
Paranormal Activity the ghost dimension
is supposedly the last Paranormal
Activity movie and in grand-finale form
it gives you none of the finale flavor
but this one of course is in 3d they
hadn't jumped on the 3d bandwagon yet
but now a 3d this Paranormal Activity
movie is fascinating because it really
goes against everything that made
Paranormal Activity enjoyable in the
first place Paranormal Activity was kind
of divisive some people thought it was a
really tension-filled and creepy other
people thought it was boring but it also
had a lot of tension that you really
didn't see in movies like this before it
came from the fact that you don't see
this demon you don't see this thing you
just kind of find out it's there but not
seeing is actually creepier than saying
this movie throws that concept right out
the window right now let's just show you
everything ultimately the Venom symbiote
from spider-man is haunting this house
and you see it all the time because the
dude finds this magic camera that can
see the ghost so now you just could see
everything in 3d so that's the gimmick
of the movie and is if that doesn't
sound bad enough you have cookie cutter
characters that are ultimately re skins
of the characters who were in the
previous movie you got the mother you
have the father you have the friend or
uncle or whoever it is you have that
other person who's also the friend and
you had the little kid who can see the
ghost and talk to it it's like here we
go again you have the option of seeing
this movie in 2d by popping on one of
the previous Paranormal Activity movies
in fact you have an option of seeing a
creepier version of this movie because
in the other Paranormal Activity movies
you don't actually see the ghost at
least in the other Paranormal Activity
movies when the boring characters are
doing boring ass you still feel
like there is a presence but you don't
know what it is you know the first
Paranormal Activity movie when the shits
going down the girl was like I hear
something you hear this and her hair
blows you're like oh my god the thing
was like right next door and I didn't
know that in this movie the same thing
would kind of happened but you would see
it be like honey the Christmas tree
looks really nice I just I really like
the colors I like the color scheme it it
really is it I like it I think it's
gonna be good oh my god I feel something
so Street just done when you see it it
just takes away the tension especially
when the thing looks like a tendril
filled formless CGI mass and the jump
scares my god the jump scares these jump
scares are everywhere and you know when
they're gonna happen you might as well
have a countdown a life right to one see
that coming only absolutely didn't it
being the final paranormal activity you
feel like this might bring it all
together and you feel like everything's
gonna have relevance and it's gonna have
what you feel like is a finale it
doesn't feel like a finale it feels like
the end of any other paranormal activity
movie in fact by the end of this movie
you feel like the Paranormal Activity
saga is 1 2 3 and the ghost dimension 4
on the marked ones I guess don't matter
because it isn't tiny to with them
and speaking of tension and previous
Paranormal Activity movies that did
better Paranormal Activity 2 I think
even three at the end it was just really
claustrophobic feeling scenario where
someone's going through a house or a
room you know something Sara died those
claustrophobic moments and found footage
movies they actually kind of get me even
if the movies are that moment will
give me goosebumps
this one is an exorcism which you've
seen happen a hundred times before in
movies but other movies have done it
better this is just an exorcism with a
big CGI demon and garbage guys in the
end the Paranormal Activity movies it
started out as a good idea and then it
just we ended up here like any good idea
a studio took it and just tap that well
until it was dry more like alright ah
let's move on Paranormal Activity that
ghost dimension is still dog all
right so paranormal activity that goes
dimension have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more